today a jury will begin deliberations in
the trial of three men accused of
murdering ahmad arberry travis mcmichael
his father gregory and william roddy
bryan could face life in prison if
convicted they have all pleaded not
guilty to the charges omar villafranca
spoke to arberry's mother
i think if the jurors paid very very
close attention took very good notes to
their see what actually happened to a
model on that day ahmad arbury's mother
wanda cooper jones has been in the
courtroom every day as prosecutors and
defense attorneys tell very different
stories on how and why her son died
he was running on county roads on public
roads my mom wasn't doing anything wrong
that was prosecutor linda denikovsky's
argument as she took aim at the three
defendants monday saint travis mcmichael
gregory mcmichael and william roddy
bryan had no cause to kill arbory
because he had committed no crime and
they made their decision to attack a mod
artery in their driveways
because he was
a black man
running down the street
defense attorneys argued the defendants
were conducting a citizen's arrest and
that travis mcmichael shot arbory in
self-defense
that despite mcmichael's testimony on
thursday that arbory did not threaten
him he has not threatened you
no hasn't pulled out a gun
no man hasn't pulled out a knife
he did not gregory mcmichael's attorney
tried to paint arbory as responsible for
what happened
no one but a mod arbory
made the decision to either reach for
or certainly give the very real
impression that he was reaching for a
handgun
and roddy bryant's attorney argued his
client was simply filming what happened
and cooperated with authorities roddy
bryant certainly was not aware of any
intention on the part of travis
mcmichael to shoot mr arbory cooper
jones left the courtroom after one
defense attorney made comments about her
son's appearance the day of the shooting
with no socks
to cover his long
dirty toenails you got up and left yes
why
i didn't expect them to go that low i'll
just say this regardless of how long and
how dirty his toenails were
that's still my son
and he didn't deserve to die the way
that he died
outside the courtroom demonstrators
marched around the courthouse in support
of the arbory family and the judge
actually had to move the jury into an
interior room so they wouldn't hear the
demonstrators they'll be back inside
that room to deliberate after the
state's final rebuttal nate
thank you so much omar
that toenail comment nate i'm still
sitting with that tony it's whether it's
true or not true i thought it was so
cruel and so
inappropriate and really irrelevant to
what is happening in this case well ma's
mother said it best i didn't believe
they'd go so low it was cruel i thought
it was so low i thought it was extremely
cruel yeah i thought it was demeaning as
well